ah
hola bienvenidos al debate de france 24
soy santiago lópez gonzález hay gran
controversia entre los son reinos de
españa y marruecos y el territorio de
sahara occidental- la decisión del
presidente del gobierno español que
consideró la iniciativa de autonomía del
sahara occidental- dentro de marruecos
como la base seria más realista y
también más creíble para terminar con el
capítulo de descolonización de este
territorio escuchemos las palabras del
ministro josé manuel álvarez quien es el
ministro de exteriores de españa y en
ese sentido españa considera que la
iniciativa de autonomía presentada en
2007 es la base más seria realista y
creíble para la resolución de este
diferendo
se trata de un giro histórico en torno a
esta cuestión en la que el país ibérico
ha sido neutral y ha estado alineado con
la organización de naciones unidas ahora
esta postura que ha generado descontento
tanto en el gobierno español como en la
sociedad de ese país el presidente del
gobierno justifica su posición como la
mejor manera de llevar buenas relaciones
con marruecos pero que hay del sahara
occidental- en qué posición queda el
resultado de todas esas negociaciones es
un buen resultado para españa y es un
buen resultado también para marruecos es
no solamente un punto en el que cerramos
una crisis que efectivamente tuvo su
visibilización más dura más contundente
es el pasado 18 de mayo del año 2021
pero creo que no es solamente cerrar ese
capítulo lo más importante es que
sentamos las bases de una relación mucho
más sólida mucho más fuerte
con el reino de marruecos y en ese
sentido creo que aspectos que se
consolidan en esta nueva relación
vinculados con la seguridad
vinculados con el control migratorio
relacionados también con los sólidos
vínculos económicos y comerciales que
tenemos con marruecos este es un acuerdo
entre el gobierno de españa y el reino
de marruecos y efectivamente nosotros
con argelia tenemos también unas
extraordinarias relaciones y desde luego
para españa tanto marruecos como argelia
conforman bueno pues una relación
y estratégica
unos socios que son aliados en múltiples
ámbitos y que estoy convencido de que
vamos a seguir siéndolo durante los
próximos años bueno pues ahí lo tenía en
la posición oficial de españa frente a
este tema pero ustedes nuestra audiencia
en américa latina' se preguntarán qué es
el saber occidental porque le interesa
españa ya marruecos muy pero muy
brevemente les voy a dar algunos datos
clave para que entiendan cuál es la
situación en el extremo oeste de áfrica
está el territorio de sahara occidental
que limita con el océano atlántico
marruecos mauritania y argelia tiene una
extensión de unos 266 mil kilómetros
cuadrados y allí viven poco más de 580
mil personas su capital es la ciudad de
el aaiún algunos datos y fechas
importantes para tener en cuenta en 1476
los españoles construyeron sus primeros
asentamientos allí en este territorio
pero sólo hasta el siglo 19 no se
consolidó este territorio como una
colonia española en 1967 la onu
recomendó la descolonización del
territorio como parte de ese proceso de
descolonización en el continente
africano en el que otros países como
francia
como portugal el reino unido- entregaron
algunos de sus territorios para volver
los territorios o países independientes
en 1969 fue creada la provincia del
sahara español dejando de ser así
entonces este territorio una colonia y
pasando a ser una provincia más del
reino de españa para 1973 fue creado el
frente polisario un grupo que buscaba la
independencia del territorio de españa
1976 españa precisamente abandona el
sahara español y éste es ocupado por
marruecos que es el país vecino el
vecino del norte un país que lo reclamó
durante muchos años como parte de su
territorio en 1976 el frente polisario
proclamó allí la república árabe
saharaui democrática en una porción de
el territorio del sahara occidental
pues esta república es reconocida por
poco más de 80 países pero no por
naciones unidas a los ojos de la
comunidad internacional el proceso de
descolonización del sáhara occidental
está inconcluso y desde el territorio
buscan la realización de un referendo de
autodeterminación pero el último
movimiento que ha dado españa fue
sacudió fue un sacudón para el tablero y
reactivó este conflicto y generó todo
tipo de incertidumbre sobre el futuro
que pueda tener este territorio qué
razones tiene españa para haber tomado
las decisiones que ha anunciado en los
últimos días que dicen desde la
república saharaui cómo aprovechar a
marruecos este espaldarazo que le está
dando madrid a su propuesta de
considerar el sahara occidental- una
provincia con algunos grados de
autonomía dentro del reino de marruecos
que tienen que decir los organismos
internacionales como por ejemplo la
organización de naciones unidas también
los países vecinos que se han
involucrado en este conflicto y en esta
disputa a lo largo de los años estamos
hablando de mauritania y de argelia cuál
es el futuro del sáhara occidental' pues
lo vamos a analizar en el debate de fran
24 y para analizar este tema saludamos a
taleb al ali salem él es activista
político saharaui y él se encuentra en
la ciudad de madrid en españa y desde
washington en eeuu se conecta también a
esta conversación samir venid él es el
consejero político y redactor jefe de
mar loco world news ustedes también
nuestros televidentes pueden participar
en este debate pueden dejar todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas lo pueden
hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
france24 bajo esa santi logo que es mi
cuenta personal les recuerdo que la
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas en torno a este tema que tal
vez es una realidad un poco alejada de
la realidad de américa latina pero es un
tema que está empezando a calar a nivel
internacional está empezando a generar
muchas preguntas en diferentes
organismos entre ellos la unión europea
vamos a comenzar entonces con taleb en
la ciudad de madrid' preguntándole
precisamente por el origen de las
disputas recientes y de las
controversias recientes y es la decisión
que ha tomado madrid
darle espaldarazo a esa propuesta hecha
por marruecos hace algunos años ya de
que el sahara occidental- pase a ser un
territorio con cierto grado de autonomía
dentro del reino de marruecos
tenemos buenas noches santiago gracias
por tratar este tema gracias por tenerme
aquí lo que respecta al sáhara
occidental en primer lugar tenemos que
aclarar que cuando se habla del sáhara
occidental se está hablando de la última
colonia en áfrica según las naciones
unidas en el sahara occidental como bien
has explicado en este resumen es el
último territorio pendiente de
descolonización en áfrica la potencia
colonizadora que constante las naciones
unidas y que todavía es potencia
colonizadora es españa ya que nunca
llevó a cabo ese proceso de
descolonización según los reglamentos de
las naciones unidas- lo que hizo fue
entregar el territorio a marruecos y
hasta el momento ni las naciones unidas
ni la unión africana ni la unión europea
ni ningún organismo jurídico
internacional reconoce la soberanía de
marruecos sobre esos territorios por lo
cual la última palabra para decidir el
futuro del sahara occidental la tiene el
pueblo saharaui no la puede tener pedro
sánchez no la puede tener donald trump y
la puede tener nadie es el pueblo
saharaui el que debe elegir su futuro a
través de un referéndum en lo que
respecta a esta decisión tomada por el
gobierno español quien éste está claro
que el gobierno español ha respondido a
los 30 hess que ya llevan muchos años
por parte de marruecos en materia de
inmigración ilegal que marruecos envía
mucha inmigración ilegal como forma de
presión política y también en materia de
seguridad que amenaza con cortar el
flujo de intercambio de seguridad con lo
cual lo que está haciendo madrid lo que
está haciendo el gobierno español no es
respeta la legalidad internacional y la
bruta del pueblo saharaui sino como tú
bien has dicho intentar apoyar a
marruecos sucumbiendo a este chantaje si
bueno más adelante vamos a retomar la
comunicación con nuestro otro invitado
con su amiga en la ciudad de washington
vamos a restablecer la conexión con él
para conocer el otro lado de la
situación el otro lado de la moneda para
tener aquí balance en cuanto al manejo
de este tema sigue conversando entonces
con taleb en la ciudad de madrid para
entender la situación allí al interior
de la república árabe saharaui lo que se
puede entender allí con este mensaje que
ha dado claro madrid esta posición que
mantiene pedro sánchez y su gobierno
sobre esta decisión que dicen allí que
comentan allí las autoridades de este
territorio y los árabes
bueno hay que retirarse nombrado a su
mencionado la república saharaui que fue
declarada justo cuando salió el
colonialismo español los saharauis
declaramos nuestra república
independiente es cierto que no está
reconocida por las naciones unidas que
todavía sigue pendiente de descolonizar
este territorio es lo que integran
naciones unidas pero la república
saharaui se reconocida con el órgano
africano más importante que es la unión
africana la república saharaui es
miembro de ese de ese organismo como lo
es marruecos dos estados independientes
dentro de la unión aplican a las
autoridades saharauis han declarado que
esta declaración del gobierno español
viene para por supuesto agradar a
marruecos en un intento de salvaguardar
esas relaciones que hay entre ambos pero
que atentan directamente contra el
derecho del pueblo saharaui a existir
libres sobre su tierra y lo más
importante es que saca a españa de ese
proceso legal de las naciones unidas-
españa ahora mismo que en esta decisión
se encuentra completamente fuera de la
legalidad internacional
establecimos la comunicación con samir
en la ciudad de washington samir punto
de partida para este debate le doy la
bienvenida al programa es su opinión
sobre esta decisión que ha tomado madrid
en los últimos días sobre
darle respaldo a esa postura de que el
sáhara occidental se vuelva a una región
autónoma dentro de marruecos
primero gracias por la invitación antes
de responder a su
su cosa cuestión me gustaría primero
aclarar algunas algunas algunos datos
históricos históricos que su invitado ha
tratado de
terminar en para dar la impresión de que
existe de verdad una república árabe
saharaui en el sur de marruecos primero
el neo no existe una tarde república
usted dijo que es reconocida por región
de 80 países eso fue hace 20 años hoy en
día sólo 27 países de los cuales 17 en
áfrica reconoce el pan está la república
proclamada del polisario el segundo
punto en el lenguaje de la 1 no existe
una comunidad que se llama la república
árabe saharaui nunca dice la 1 con la
excepción de las de dos resoluciones de
la de la estabilidad general en 1979 80
en las cuales describió la presencia de
marruecos
ocupación desde entonces la 1 nunca ha
utilizado la palabra ocupación nosotros
sabemos que el conflicto está en las
manos desde el consejo de seguridad que
no nunca ha descrito la tesis de
marruecos en el sáhara como ocupación
con lo cual lo que es lo que estoy
invitado
ha dicho es sólo una manera de tratar de
mantener una propaganda y de tratar de
dar la impresión de que sí existe una
república al sur de
marruecos tenemos que estar claros con
el lenguaje creo que cada uno está
utilizando para para tener un debate
rico para que la gente para que los
televidentes salgan con una información
objetiva
si precisamente usted como ciudadano
marroquí
queremos conocer aquí en américa latina
hay muy poca información sobre este tema
quiero conocer cuál es la postura de
marruecos sobre este tema porque
marruecos invadió el territorio del
sahara occidental porque lo reclama como
parte de su territorio y porque mantiene
esta disputa con el frente polisario y
con españa esto ha sido hay muchos años
ya lo hemos visto
explícanos el punto de vista de este
país africano
primero tenemos que andar con cuidado
con el lenguaje que utilizamos marruecos
nunca invadió el sáhara la invasión con
la segunda el delito de derecho
internacional ocurre cuando un país en
balde a un estado preexistente a la
invasión lo cual nunca ha ocurrido con
el saja porque el sáhara usted ha
hablado cuando hablo de los datos
históricos a salto desde 1492 hasta 1907
169 como se entregan ambas ambas fechas
no había hubiera existido nada ella no
ha hablado del hecho de que marruecos en
el sáhara siempre ha pertenecido a
marruecos y que existe que existen
documentos históricos firmados por
colonias europeas que por potencias
europeas como reino unido que firmó con
marruecos y en marzo de 1895 un acuerdo
según el cual los
reino unido reconoció la pertenencia del
sáhara
marruecos no no podemos pasar por alto
estos datos históricos y si tuviera
bastante tiempo para explicar lo que
pasó en 1904 y más adelante
precisamente lo que no tenemos es tiempo
y le estoy preguntando por la posición
de marruecos no nos vayamos a esos datos
históricos que entiendo que son
importantes pero quiero conocer en
detalle cuál es la postura de marruecos
frente a este tema por favor pero la
primera la posición de marruecos es que
el sahara siempre ha pertenecido a
marruecos que fue arrebatado a marruecos
durante el período colonial a través de
un acuerdo entre el reino unido francia
españa y 1904 de que este territorio
siempre ha sido marroquí y que marruecos
desde
1957 fue el primer país que reclamó a
españa descolonizar el territorio yo me
pregunto si si el sáhara así es de sahar
perteneció a una república
donde estaba estaban estos saharauis
entre
1959 hasta 1973 con cuanto se fue creado
el polisario empezó a proclamar a
reclamar a la creación de un estado
independiente para marruecos en sáhara
es marroquí y por eso no no puede
aceptar ninguna solución que no se
adecue con sus derechos históricos y
legales con respecto al territorio que
lo que españa hizo hasta las derbi su
declaración el viernes es sólo reconoce
reconocer estos datos históricos y
corregir un
error históricos hacia marruecos el
publicitario aquí bueno tal vez le
trasladó la pregunta entonces cómo
entender la posición de marruecos ya
también nos ha explicado un poco de la
parte histórica la posición marroquí
cuál es el sentido desde el lado
saharaui
bueno como te comenté diciendo el sáhara
occidental es un territorio que
pertenece al pueblo saharaui es el
pueblo saharaui el que debe decidir el
futuro y el destino de este territorio
ni marruecos ni españa ni francia y sólo
corrigiendo nosotros no transversales
por supuesto creo que somos muy
coherentes en nuestro planteamiento creo
que hablamos siempre con la legalidad
internacional en la mano desde la
primera resolución de las naciones
unidas- la 3 de 14 que se hizo en el año
58 se reconocía el derecho del pueblo
saharaui a ser un estado independiente
las declaraciones de courtois del que
era el secretario general de las
naciones unidas en el año 75 calificó de
ocupación ilegal la presencia de
marruecos en el sáhara occidental y en
allianz en el año 2016 hemos visto como
el ex secretario general de las naciones
unidas ban ki-moon visitaba los
campamentos de refugiados saharauis y
cito literalmente lo que dijo desde las
naciones unidas- trabajaremos para
acabar con la ocupación ilegal de
marruecos a vuestros territorios por lo
cual yo no estoy traje versando y estas
son palabras de las naciones unidas- de
sus secretarios generales que todo el
mundo puede comprobar en internet porque
hoy tenemos internet y todo el mundo
puede comprar estas verdades por
supuesto la posición de marruecos es la
de ocupar el territorio del sahara
occidental y buscar una forma de
legitimar esta ocupación lo ha intentado
con la declaración de trampa a través de
'twitter' hace bueno hace un año de esta
declaración y hablo marruecos de que
esta declaración suponía el fin de este
conflicto ya que donald trump raramente
le había entregado el sáhara occidental'
yo lo intenta con españa a través del
chantaje pero finalmente y para resumir
y la conclusión es que en sáhara
occidental' pertenece al pueblo saharaui
está registrado ante la naciones unidas
y será el pueblo saharaui que identidad
en un referéndum en el futuro de este
territorio vale ustedes y en su
intervención anterior que españa
prácticamente se está saliendo de la
responsabilidad que le corresponde aquí
en este proceso de descolonización que
ha tenido un montón de tropiezos como lo
estamos viendo esta españa lavándose las
manos de las responsabilidades que le
corresponden aquí tal y como lo ha
presentado el gobierno del presidente
pedro sánchez del presidente del
gobierno y qué repercusiones puede traer
para el territorio para las relaciones
con marruecos para la relación con
argelia y con la misma españa
y bueno para empezar españa se lavó las
manos del territorio de este conflicto
en el año 75 cuando se lo entregó a
marruecos a través de lo que se conoce
como los acuerdos tripartitos de madrid
y esto está documentado y está publicado
en las instituciones españolas que es un
acuerdo que se firmó en madrid donde
españa entregaba el territorio del
sahara occidental a marruecos y
mauritania que en aquel entonces también
reclamaba el territorio y extrañamente
de marruecos firmó este acuerdo
queriendo la mitad del territorio del
sahara occidental a mauritania o sea era
cómo repartirse una tarta españa se
intentó grabar las manos entonces dijo
que el conflicto estaba acabado con esta
entrega por que salvaguardó sus
intereses económicos en la zona pero
casi 50 años aquí estamos aquí está el
pueblo saharaui luchando con sus
derechos y ahí está todas las
resoluciones de alarma tiene subidas que
insisten en que españa tiene que asumir
esta responsabilidad y aquí brevemente
me gustaría remarcar que esta posición
no es la posición de españa estamos
sintiendo el apoyo del pueblo español
estamos sintiendo el apoyo de todos los
partidos políticos incluso de la parte
que está gobernando estamos también
sintiendo el apoyo de mí están dentro
del gobierno sabemos que la comunidad
internacional ha llamado mucho la
atención esta posición de españa este
giro que ha dado madrid con estos
anuncios recientes
y vemos que hay poco apoyo de la
ciudadanía hay controversia incluso
dentro del gobierno español dentro de el
mismo partido del presidente del
gobierno pedro sánchez a marruecos quien
lo apoya a nivel internacional en esta
lucha en esta cruzada por este
territorio
pues marruecos le está apoyado por un
censo caricia internacional creciente en
el consejo de seguridad que es quien que
a quien debate sobre el conflicto desde
hace 32 años en el conceder a todas las
resoluciones adoptadas desde 2007 dice
que no habrá solución al conflicto
si no hay diálogo entre las partes él
dice clara sólo que la solución debe ser
la 6 solución consensuada
hay mucha mucha mucha mente aceptable
para las partes del problema es que el
polisario apoyado por argelia quien ha
creado este conflicto y quien ha usado
el polisario en su lucha por la
hegemonía del magreb desde hace 47 años
no quiere que no quiere que este
conflicto se termine porque argelia sabe
que una solución del conflicto a
beneficio de marruecos la afectaría y la
limitaría y sería en vez de contribuir a
contribuiría a
a marruecos no quiso en lo que es hoy su
invitado a ha pasado por por alto es que
si los es para los saharauis son los que
deberían decidir el futuro del
territorio porque porque el polisario y
argelia desde hace 11 años se rechazan a
todas las demandas de polis del consejo
de seguridad para llevar a cabo un censo
en los campamentos de tindúf para saber
cuántos en cuantos saharauis están aquí
y de dónde proviene lo que o lo que pasa
colocadas lo que pasa por alto es que no
quieren hacerlo porque saben de antemano
que hay una gran mayoría de saharauis
que están en los campamentos de tindúf
que no son oriundos de sahara pero son
oriundos de diciendo de tindúf en misma
porque no que la mayoría de la gente no
sabe es que los saharauis sobre todo la
tribu de arriba es que es la tribu más
mayoritaria del 10 aja está dispersa por
todo el sáhara desde marruecos hasta
argelia está y libia es sólo el
polisario se rechaza a esto porque no
quiere que el mundo se integre de esta
fechoría de esa
que el segundo
en
uno que es la existencia de un pueblo
saharaui así que si queremos hablar bien
pueblo saharaui este pueblo salgo en
barca desde el sur de marruecos hasta el
sur de libia incluir la alusión
inclusive a argelia marruecos está en su
posición está apoyada por grandes
potencias pero apoya los estados unidos
francia españa alemania en el futuro sea
también apoyado por otras potencias
europeas
a eso añado que hasta hoy en día 25
países han abierto sus consulados en el
sáhara mientras tanto el apoyo por la
autoproclamada república del polisario
está decreciendo hace dos décadas 6 am y
había 80 países que reconocían esta
dicha dicha auto por cábala república
hoy en día son 17 porque porque la gente
se está dando cuenta de que ya la
existencia de un territorio al sur de
marruecos no es realizable es un sueño
samir muy interesante su punto de vista
le pido por favor sea más puntual con
las respuestas porque se nos acaba el
tiempo y tengo muchas preguntas para
hacerles muy importante el punto de
vista que usted nos está dando y pasó a
preguntarle samir por favor puntual
españa está coqueteando con marruecos
con este tema para evitar más llegada de
inmigrantes como los que tuvimos hace
unos meses atrás en los enclaves de
ceuta y melilla y tal vez por ese esa
nueva página en las relaciones que se
está abriendo entre españa y argelia por
la posibilidad de reactivar un gasoducto
que lleve gas desde territorio argelino
a través del magreb a través de
marruecos al territorio español
precisamente para poder suplir las
necesidades de gas que va a tener la
unión europea de cara a cortar el
suministro procedente de rusia por la
invasión al territorio ucraniano como
parte de las sanciones no está madrid
coqueteando les colgaron con esta excusa
de por medio no creo que esa sea la
razón primero tendría que sólo remarcar
que la posición de pedro sanz es no
significa un giro histórico de españa
porque hay que hay que
recalcar que en 2008 el entonces
presidente del gobierno español
rodríguez zapatero había calificado
virtual de autonomía marroquí como serio
increíble
tildó los esfuerzos de marruecos de
contribución positiva al proceso
político por eso hay que remarcarlo
porque hay mucha gente que dice que hizo
un giro histórico de 10 180 grados
etcétera pero no lo es sólo es una
evolución
natural de la posición de españa que
tiene muchos intereses con marruecos
intereses económicos secretarios que
también tenemos lazos culturales
históricos y dice que hay que poner
y que la relación entre españa y
marruecos no
gira solo en torno al tema migratorio no
olvidemos que españa tiene más de 1000
empresas españolas que con marruecos y
que marruecos es el primer socio
islamista económico de hispania en
áfrica el mundo árabe que es panista
primer primer socio económico de
marruecos y que tiene siempre una plaza
con un balance comercial que le es
favorable por él a españa ahora se ha
dado cuenta de que está ahí su interés
para la estabilidad para la paz y para
la prosperidad de ambos pueblos si se
miran este tema que ha terminado
habla samir de una evolución en cuanto a
la posición de españa frente a este tema
frente a la posición que puede tener por
el sahara occidental vemos que hay
muchos intereses con marruecos pero qué
intereses tiene entonces con el sáhara
occidental o esto es una evolución
simplemente en ese abandono ya histórico
como lo deja en evidencia los hechos a
lo largo de los años
bueno antes de contestar a su pregunta
de forma muy breve voy a contestar a
bueno a todo el bochorno que se ha
soltado aquí se contradicen nuestro
invitado en su exposición de los hechos
primero dice que no existe un pueblo
saharaui y después dice que marruecos
ofrece la autonomía al pueblo saharaui
primero dice que el sáhara siempre ha
sido parte de marruecos y luego dice que
incluso argelia y libia pertenecían y
aranda barrer la soberanía de estos dos
estados y dice que también pertenecían a
marruecos esto deja claro también en que
marruecos está en una posición siempre
hay una ideología de expansionismo que
no sólo invade el sáhara occidental' de
forma ilegal sino que también tiene
reclamos sobre argelia tiene reclamos
sobre mauritania y este es el fondo del
problema el expansionismo y la ideología
imperialista del régimen que hay en
marruecos en cuanto a su pregunta yo
creo que españa intereses en el sáhara
occidental e intereses en marruecos
siempre ha tenido pero es verdad que
marruecos ha sabido utilizar esos
intereses que tiene españa sobre todo
intereses económicos para presionarle
cuando hablamos de que marruecos
chantaje de presión a españa no sólo en
materia de seguridad o de inmigración
sino también sobre
de ceuta y melilla que marruecos reclama
de forma continua y que intenta también
posee eso hasta el momento es marruecos
no reconoce la soberanía de españa sobre
esos territorios pero lejos de todo esto
lo que no puede ser una hoja de cambio
lo que no puede ser moneda de cambio es
el derecho inalienable del pueblo
saharaui a existir libres sobre su
tierra cuando hablamos del conflicto del
sáhara occidental' estamos hablando como
he mencionado antes de una
descolonización la presencia de
marruecos en el sáhara oriental que es
ilegal y abrir consulados en el sáhara
occidental como digo que declara pedro
sánchez o que lo haga tan tonal trump
esto no justifica ni modifica la natural
la naturaleza del conflicto y que es una
descolonización pendiente ante las
naciones unidas y como bien has
mencionado santiago el portavoz de las
naciones unidas hace dos días declaró
que están completamente en contra de
esta decisión y que cualquier decisión
para el sahara occidental debe de ser
bajo el paraguas de las naciones unidas
que presenta de un referéndum para el
sáhara occidental por lo cual remarcó
aquí también un poco lo que ha dicho
nuestro invitado no hay ningún problema
con los censados no hay ningún problema
con los que tienen que votar
dejo una lista de todos los saharauis
que estaban bajo
bajo bueno que vivían bajo lo que es la
ocupación española hay una lista de los
30 pensados que pueden votar sin ningún
problema por lo cual marruecos se está
poniendo trabas y yo creo que tarde o
temprano vamos a ver este referéndum
producirse porque marruecos se encuentra
y nunca hizo en su salida todos sus
intentos brevemente todos sus intentos
de huida hacia adelante se encuentra con
la legalidad ente matinal que le
recuerda que su presente en el sáhara
occidental es y llegando tal vez
brevemente entonces el fin de toda esta
historia la posible salida de este túnel
es un referendo de autodeterminación en
este territorio africano sería la única
solución no hay un margen de negociación
marruecos el aaiún madrid
puede ser así o como lo ve usted
solamente el referéndum si no está
firmado así en el año 91 madrid del
sáhara occidental y marruecos firmaron
un acuerdo para realizar este referéndum
y tengo que decir que no se rechaza la
autonomía que presenta a marruecos ni se
rechaza que el sáhara vuelva a ser
territorio español pero que éstos sean
decisiones junto a la independencia del
pueblo saharaui vote creo que esta es la
solución más usted creo que es la
solución que defiende la unión africana
la unión europea y las naciones unidas y
tarde o temprano es la solución a la que
vamos a llegar porque no hay otra vía
porque no se le puede imponer al pueblo
saharaui nada ni sánchez ni marruecos ni
nadie puede imponerle al pueblo saharaui
en que no hay dirija a través de un
referéndum samir me quedan pocos minutos
para finalizar el programa quiero
conocer entonces para usted cuál sería
la solución entonces de todo este
problema un referendo de
autodeterminación tal y como lo lo puede
decir la organización mundial en la
organización de naciones unidas a nivel
internacional vivir un proceso de
independencia o cual puede ser entonces
la salida a este a este conflicto que no
tiene todavía un punto final atrás
experimento primero sólo corregir
algunas de realizaciones de los hechos
por freír por su mitad o ha dicho que yo
he dicho que mandan los saharauis
directora de argelia y libia pretensión
a marruecos yo no he dicho esto digo
dijo dije que los sabios y existen en el
sur de marjah mostrar gel ya hasta libia
no hay expansión es un marroquí y de esa
es una mentira siempre repetida por los
saharauis para conseguir
y la opinión pública internacional según
la dgt prestación cuando el viejo que el
portavoz ha dicho que no está opuesta a
lo que lo que ha hecho españa es una
pura mentira y no hay nada respecto de
las naciones y les tercer punto ha dicho
que el polisario y argelia siempre están
preparados para descenso es otra pura
mentira desde desde hace 11 años el
polisario de argelia siempre se ha
rechazado a una hora que haya un recreo
un censo en el
sitio para que el para que el mundo sepa
con cuántas personas está ni que quiere
son ritmos de ahí no ha dicho también
que hay una contradicción entre lo que
dije no hay contradicción cual
contradicción cuando digo que marruecos
está como a está abierto a una autonomía
actual para el comparar una solución de
conflicto porque marruecos sabe que la
historia está disimulado y que los haga
la mayoría de los saharauis que estaban
registrados en el censo en 1974 están
ahora viviendo a las últimas argelia no
quiere que el mundo sepa quién es estar
ahí porque sabe sabe de antemano que en
su mayoría no son del sáhara para ver
propiamente dicho pero que son del sur
del sur
de tindúf en la solución al conflicto
que me he dicho es una una solución a
través de la autonomía bajo marroquí es
no es la es el mundo está yendo en esta
dirección y por más que haga lo que diga
argelia y el polisario no habrá nunca un
estado independiente al sur de marte por
la simple razón porque nunca ha existido
ha existido en esta zona un
país con
una colonia una invasión es sólo una
pura desinformación e tercerización de
los datos y hechos históricos es en lo
cual los
más del polisario siempre son excelentes
bueno me quedan ya pocos segundos para
terminar el programa quiero conocer
entonces la conclusión de este tema con
nuestros invitados amir por favor 30
segundos para terminar el programa sea
puntual por favor en su intervención la
conclusión que va a suceder esto va a
generar más controversia va a pasar con
el paso de los días simplemente va a
bajar un poco la espuma de este hecho y
se olvidará y quedará ahí simplemente
como una anécdota más en este gobierno
español que piensa usted esté usted
seguro que no va a haber ni controversia
ni nada lo mismo ocurrió conductor
siempre conoció la soberanía marroquí
sobre el sáhara y dije y dijeron que
bailén la iba a revertirse nada de eso
ocurrió yo estoy seguro le puedo
asegurar que si va a va a hacer que
otros países tomen el paso de spam de
mosca de marroquí sobre el sáhara tal es
rápidamente su conclusión muy puntual
por favor
bueno me gustaría felicitar a su
invitado porque domina el arte del cine
ha creado su propia película en estos
minutos que hemos estado hablando
simplemente de forma muy variable
decirle hay una misión que es la misión
de las naciones unidas que estén para un
referéndum claro
está presente en los campamentos y está
presente en el sáhara cuando marruecos
de tiras evita la realidad sobre el
terreno tendremos una solución que elija
el pueblo saharaui taleb también muchas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros en
el programa y ustedes muchas gracias por
la sintonía
[Música]